First off, as you may have noticed, your tongue
is coated with saliva (shocker, I know), which
is about 99.5 percent water.
In order for the tongue to not freeze when
sufficiently cold, the body sends blood rushing
to the tongue to heat it up.
However, metal, in nearly all of its forms,
is a great conductor of heat, meaning that
heat relatively freely transfers through it.
If something conducts heat well, (most of
the time) you can feel it - literally, which
is why something like a metal wrench kept
at 25 degrees Fahrenheit (-3C) feels much
colder to your skin than air at the same temperature.
Of the common metals, copper and aluminum
are best at this.
Some of the most expensive cookware is made
out of copper due to its characteristic as
a thermal conductor.
As for aluminum, there is a reason tin - or
aluminum - foil is a common household item
and is often used in ovens.
(And if you're curious see our video: Why
is Aluminum Foil Shiny on One Side But Not
the Other?)
While iron conducts heat at about a third
of the rate as aluminum, it still does it
quite well.
Stainless steel conducts heat at about a fifth
of the rate as iron but is also often used
as kitchenware, as it's still relatively great
at conducting heat.
On the other hand, wood, plastic, and rubber
are not good heat conductors, with wood being
150 times less conductive than stainless steel.
That is why when you stir a boiling pot with
a wooden spoon, you can hardly feel the heat
in the handle.
With a solid steel, aluminum, iron, or copper
spoon, if you continued stirring like you
would with the wood spoon, you would quickly
find yourself with a nice burn for your efforts.
So, what really happens when you put your
warm tongue on a cold flagpole?
When the tongue makes contact with the pole,
the heat is rapidly transferred, cooling the
tongue and forcing the body to send warmth
in the form of blood and heat energy.
The problem is that, today, most metal flag
poles are made up of aluminum or steel (an
iron alloy with carbon), making them fine
heat conductors.
The pole absorbs the heat quite readily, literally
sucking the warmth from your tongue faster
than your body can supply it.
The saliva on your tongue then freezes (provided
it is below freezing), with the resulting
ice latching onto the flagpole and your very
porous tongue.
You are stuck.
Materials that are less ideal conductors of
heat won't provide this same rapid effect,
nor even in many cases are they capable of
cooling the surface of your tongue faster
than your body can heat it to keep it above
freezing.
In some cases, the material might even have
an insulating effect.
The more important question is, if found in
this situation, how do you get unstuck?
First off, do not pull or tug.
If it is really cold and really stuck, there
is a risk that a piece of tongue will come
right off, causing much pain and blood.
Thankfully, there is a simple solution- pour
warm water over where the tongue meets the
pole, warming your tongue, the pole, and melting
the ice.
Of course, this is difficult to do without
help when you're stuck to a pole.
If by yourself, try breathing hot breathes
onto the area.
The moisture and warm air should dislodge
the tongue.
One could also try using warm hands and fingers
to melt the ice.
If none of these things work, call the local
fire station.
If you find it difficult to communicate your
problem with your tongue stuck, today many
emergency call centers accept texts.
Bonus Fact:
• Some of the best solid heat conductors
are actually diamonds.
Diamonds can be up to five times better thermal
conductors than copper.
The strength of its covalent bonds creates
this characteristic, along with the strength
in general of a diamond (long considered one
of the most unbreakable items in the world,
though in truth they are often easily crushed
to dust with a simple blow from a hammer).
• Licking an icicle can also cause a stuck
tongue.
While not as a good of a heat conductor as
aluminum or iron, it is about ten times better
than rubber at this.
As a rule, just stopping licking icy things
outdoors.
Seriously.
What’s wrong with you?